هذا وكان مدير الدفاع المدني السوريه
التابع للمعارضه رائد الصالح قد ذكر انه
لم تدخل اي فرق انقاذ دوليه الى شمال غربي
سوريا
لا نستطيع ان نقول ان هناك
ما دخل فريق تطوعي من الاخوه المصريين
المقيمين في تركيا بالاضافه الى طريق صغير
من اسبانيا بدون معدات وهو مستعان في
معدات الدفاع المدني
كما اضاف مدير الدفاع المدنيه السوريه
التابع للمعارضه ان الامم المتحده لم تقدم
اي شيء وتساءل عن اسباب عدم دخول
المساعدات الى شمال غربي سوريا بينما جرى
ادخال المساعدات الى مناطق النظام
لا استطيع ان اقول الى الان الامم المتحده
لم تقدم اي شيء وانا اليوم كنت في احدى
المحادثات مع احد المسؤولين في الامم
المتحده وطالبته بالاعتذار من الشعب
السوري وطلب البارحه المندوب الامريكي في
مجلس الامن
بالمطالب بفتح تحقيق في الامم المتحده
للتحقيق لماذا حدث هذا التقصير في مناطق
شمال غرب سوريا ولماذا المساعدات وصلت الى
مناطق النظام السوري والم تصل الى مناطق
شمال غرب سوريا